athough was the elizy fool in a country
in lockdown the dead are buried without
relatives to mourn them in a cemetery in
barcelona just a solitary priest is
present to pay last respects the fate
awaiting hundreds as the death toll
continues to climb across Spain in the
capital of the country hospitals are
reaching full capacity here the holes
and waiting rooms are packed standing
room only
as they wait for someone to treat them
in another madrid hospital patients lie
on the floor because there are no beds
left josé cabañas whose mother is still
in hospital in barcelona says staff
there told him the pressure is
relentless someone said to me that when
they had like the terror attacks there
was a moment they had a lot of people
arriving at the same time but that that
was it and now it's a constant flow and
they take her difficulty managing it
how did spain become one of the worst
affected countries this may have played
a key role
thousands of Spanish football fans
travelling to Bergamo in Italy for the
Atalanta Valencia game on February the
19th the city's mayor called the game
the bomb that exploded the virus
the cheery music the Spanish government
is releasing footage of field hospitals
being built but also fighting
allegations it didn't see this outbreak
coming early enough or do enough to stop
it the increase in fatalities today is
not statistically higher than we've seen
two days ago which was showing a more
stable tendency which continues despite
today's increase more and more doctors
and nurses are becoming infected
radiologist Sergio Dario is recovering
in isolation and says the Health System
has seen nothing like it it was just a
person we're having cases of patients
dying in our hands but in absolute
solitude these patients have to be
completely isolated and they're dying in
the hands of the doctors and as health
care workers have to go home in fear of
transmitting the virus to our families
the situation has got the better of us
I've never seen so much fear in either
the faces of the patients or the health
care workers so many are dying in Madrid
the city's ice rink has become it's more
the Lori's arrived bearing the dead with
grim frequency Dominick Waghorn Sky News